taking you back to our breaking news
story out of Pakistan and there's been
an explosion at a mosque in the city of
Peshawar that's in the northwest of the
country police say that heavy casualties
are feared once again we bring in Kama
Haider he's following development out of
Islamabad Kamal what are you hearing
about the latest death and Casualty toll
well the death toll is going up it is
likely to go up given the fact that
according to hospital sources over a
dozen of them are a critically wounded
and we are also getting details that
they that this was a suicide bombing
that the suicide bomber himself was
sitting in the front row in that
congregational prayer inside a mosque in
the police lines this is an area where
the police have their residential areas
as well and it's in within a compound so
indeed an alarming situation given the
fact that this suicide bomber was
sitting amongst the worshipers how he
was able to get inside undetected of
course would also raise other questions
but important to note that this is
indeed a serious incident over 50 people
are wounded in this explosion and as I
mentioned some of them are in critical
condition according to the latest we
have at least three people are confirmed
dead there are some figures of five but
as I mentioned the dead toll is likely
to rise so why would this happen in
Peshawar now and why this particular
Moss come out
well what has happened is that the
tarika Taliban Pakistan who have uh
declared war against Pakistan they've
been attacking the police the security
forces and almost on a daily basis there
is an attempt on a police post or a
police station the police being the soft
target primarily because they're poorly
armed they're not as well equipped as
the dtp fighters these people have been
complaining they don't have proper life
fresh but this particular attack inside
the mosque is also nothing new the TTP
has been using suicide bombers isil
daesh has also been using uh suicide
bombers to Target mosques and places of
Warships uh in the past as well so
there's nothing new about that but the
fact that they have been able to
penetrate into uh what should have been
a secure compound will of course raise
questions as to the security or the
capability of the police forces they
have paid a heavy price many officials
have been killed in the past month alone
we were at a police station doing a
report on the rise or the spike in
violent attacks and that same police
station came under attack two days later
with several people being killed there
so that's the situation at the moment
thank you so much kamahaiser reporting
from islamabads